hallo leute die da waren heute werden
wir einen adventskalender auspacken von
richards diese verpackung hat mich
komplett um den finger gewickelt wenn in
letzter zeit ein großer fan von
holzprodukten geworden kann mich einfach
an dieser stelle nur sagen dieses video
ist nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle
zusammen dieses video ist nicht
geschwollen sind gucken wir mal was der
gekostet hat es gibt dieses jahr zwei
adventskalender fortschritt einer kostet
59 euro 90 das ist so ein haus und mainz
hier ist ein dorf was man für 89 90
krieg also knapp 100 euro da muss hier
wirklich die absolute party emsländer
sein dass ich das geld hätte
das ist schon der hintergrund für unser
wunderschönes dorma krass ja man muss
ihn sich jetzt mal selber zusammen
machen will ach ja ja wenn der
adventskalender erstmal in der
bastelstunde beginnt erstmal alles raus
entweder benutzt ich dieses jahr diesen
adventskalender oder ich werde ihnen
verlosen an euch auf instagram also
falls ihr bei den ganzen adventskalender
verlosung mitmachen wollt dann folgt mir
auf instagram fünf minuten ist dieser
adventskalender hier ausgepackt und es
riecht schon wie ein register so und das
letzte stück ihr bekommt man einmal die
ganze pracht zu sehen
optisch kann wer wirklich sich sehen
lassen das ist ja krass wie hübsche ist
und wenn man vorsichtig damit umgeht
sollte da eigentlich wieder verwendbar
ich habe mich gerade gewundert wo hin
dass wenn kommt in welches türchen und
das sind die christmas lights
dieser adventskalender hat eine
lichterkette für das man eine batterie
braucht ist ihr was wir können uns das
vorstellen wie das mit einer
lichterkette aussieht ich habe so viele
lichterketten ich verlose gibt der
adventskalender kostet 289 euro 90 aber
der wert nun anscheinend bei 150 euro
liegen und ich bin jetzt einfach nur
noch gespannt was drin ist türchen
nummer
häuschen nummer eins
befördert experience suite jasmin bei
leiding das kenne ich
versuche euch die gerüche so gut es geht
zu beschreiben meine mutter meine mutter
die irgendwo ein erwachsenes parfüm
benutzt
es riecht es riecht wie meine mutter die
riechen nicht schlecht ich sag das nicht
aber trägt wie meine mutter es riecht
einfach wie minute hier mal für dich
eine kerze dieser kalender macht schon
richtige weihnachtsstimmung türchen
nummer zwei
krejcik in relaxing aromatik sensation
johann philipp glock citigroup spray
ein raumspray reismilch und cherry
blossom woher dieses zimmer wird so
stinken wenn ich damit fertig bin
haben wir das auge gespritzt selbst ins
auge gewedelt
ich finde von hodges diese cherry
blossom linie die schwächste fliegt halt
sehr süß und so
lieblich und leicht und aber irgendwie
ja das problem sagt rich holzprodukte
sind so teuer dass das ja nur proben
sein können wenn man zehn duschgel daran
machen würde wenn man bei 100 euro
die nummer drei der
kadaver sind
das recht alles so intensiv dort ist
recht ganz gut ne limited edition hat es
ist zwar jetzt hier so eine bogen größe
aber wie auch hier da ist ja ordentlich
was drin und meistens braucht man ja eh
die original packungen türchen nummer
vier
eine hand lotion das himalaya honig drin
klar
meine nase gerade so
weil sie nichtiger sei sie die musters
frieden mit cranberry
das rose drin ja indische rose und suite
an ich mag keine kein rosenduft ich bin
einmal türchen
[Musik]
wisst ihr warum ich gerade so überrascht
geguckt habe weil ich dachte dass wir
diese exakt gleiche kerze schon bekommen
haben vom nokia aber die riecht nach
rose aber klar
ja
das sehe ich wie meine mutter
die gerade vom großen schneiden aus dem
garten kam ja wo ist nicolas endlich
können wir einen tannenbaum also das
macht er absolut gar keinen unterschied
war dass aber trotzdem freue ich mich
darauf den verdammten tannenbaum
aufzumachen
tolles system tolles system uhu spring
lauf nicht zu verwechseln mit dem
raumduft das hier ist ein pony duft
weißen linie und höher sich blüte
benutzt ihr eigentlich body spray
sitzplätzen zu halten mitbekommen dass
man jetzt body spray es benutzt aber
ja ich verstehe habe nicht den
unterschied zwischen verfügen und ein
body spray beides sind dürfte die latte
auf sprießt damit du angenehm riecht ich
mag aber die größe nikolaus vorbei jetzt
kommt aber der 70
[Applaus]
ich würde mal sagen das ist hier an
männer gerichtet weil es mit irgendwas
mit gut und patchouli ist und patchouli
ist immer so ein sehr heutiger deftiger
duft türchen nummer acht
da die reihe kenne ich sehr gut dass
ritschel auf mehr body muss zwei
körper guss zu öl
einfach mein lieblings luft riecht
irgendwie nach orange und holz und
[Gelächter]
marx ich mag sie betrieben ich finde
sehr komisch ist es erst schauen ist und
das öl aber anscheinend gibt es sowas
mit dem duft kriegt mich auch heute ist
meine lieblingszahl türchen nummer 9 a
ha
ja ein sehr hohen damit man sieht wird
bin jetzt leider zugekleistert mit
make-up deswegen kann ich das nicht
ausprobieren aber gute no go to have die
sorgenfalten während der weihnachtszeit
werden auch nicht weniger da wir wieder
einen tannenbaum nummer 10
ritschel of january you
spend yusen beides gut
das ist ein kissen spray
das ist der esoterische yoga studio
meditations- duft der mich so schläfrig
macht verpackt in einer flasche wenn ihr
mal in einem retweet store seit riecht
es mal und sagt mir dass ich recht habe
danke secret und lavinia lavendel na
klar heiliges holz sacred worlds
heiliges holz naja und lavendel wenn du
jetzt einfach super zum schlafengehen
das ist total der beruhigenden duft
janovic das kloster wenn ich aber nicht
auf mich drauf springen wenn ich gehe
heute noch in eine bar mit naomi und ich
möchte ja nicht dass sie einschläft
werden sie mit mir redet weil ich so
beruhigend rieche es reicht ja schon
dass ich rieche wie ein ripsdorf wie man
gespannt ob sie auffällt
was ist rittal auf hamam ein shampoo
es ist ein sehr männlicher dürftig war
dies anders beschreiben arganöl und
chicago in dem schampus aber arganöl
drin und das ist sehr gut
kirchen haben wir den kandidaten für
eine neue kerze
absolutes mimosa
also von den kerzen heidi nicht so viele
siege aus und wieder wie meine mutter
diese kerzen sind einfach verschiedene
stadien von meiner mutter meine mutter
nummer drei
wir haben was großes samurai diese reihe
drittel auf sammrey die habe ich timo
letztes jahr in seinen adventskalender
reingepackt
was ist hier los ist da daran gerade
gerochen und dachte mir warum riecht es
wie diese eis bonbons also diese bons im
blauen verpackung naja es riecht danach
weiß das eissport shower gel ist ja mag
ich absolut nicht das original ritschel
of samurai finde ich besser als diese
eis version bei die halt wirklich nach
diesem bonbon gericht was haben wir hier
einen durch run to you
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass ich mit
euch über das thema reden kann aber für
alle die hautprobleme haben gerade so am
körper zum beispiel so rothe pickelchen
trockener haut ein wachsen haare an
stellen wo dann die haut quasi so
schuppig ist eingewachsene haare nachdem
man sich rasiert hat leute ein dusch
handschuhe hat mein leben verändert seit
ich jedes mal beim duschen so ein
handschuh benutze mache ich meine du
steht da drauf und hab meinen körper ab
und die ganze tote hautschicht kann sich
lösen seitdem habe ich eine supergute
hat keiner irgendwelche probleme und das
liegt nur daran kirchen
[Musik]
du steht das ist die grüne reihe also
diese dinge reihe das ist wohl für relax
das gut
türchen nummer
was neues widget auf kammer eine
lotus und organic light also ich weiß
nicht wo nach weissert er ist aber es
riecht angenehm frisch es riecht wie in
einem sauberen
massagestudio nummer 17
ich finde das passt optisch gerade so
überhaupt nicht in das standard
design.com
[Musik]
extreme
treffer
komisches gefühl die versuchen damit
irgendwas ich glaube sie wollen damit
irgendwie hin so ein bisschen die
jüngere zielgruppe ja das ist dann
wahrscheinlich wenn mama für sich selber
so ein schöner ist so schön die kerze
holt sie dessen sagt auch meine tochter
liebt acht toll dass das hole ich ihr
so nach der 17 kommt die 18
olaf kramer mit bodies corp ist
und ich mag es
219 ein kleines haus will wissen was das
bedeutet wird meiner mama ein kleines
stück mehr nach welchem stadium meiner
mutter wird diese kerze richten
ein car die gern von meiner mama
der sohn jahr im schrank lag an den ich
jetzt anziehe
leicht muffig aber meine mutter jahre
wein heißt diese kerze von der mutter
collection natürlich verlose ich die
mutter collection und ihr könnt dann in
ruhe an meiner mutter schnüffeln türchen
nummer 20 was verbirgt sich hinter
diesem zauber gut wird das sieht auch so
überhaupt nicht typisch für schritt aus
also wieder ein body mist
ist des wirklichen bot ihm ist es
riecht ehrlich gesagt wie ein sehr
sauberes badezimmer wenn ich mal wieder
vergessen habe zu duschen und so
riecht nach sauberen badezimmer deshalb
noch schweiß
21 meine nase freut sich wir nähern uns
dem ende
das schenke ich anni das mag sie body
cream von der regel auf sakura reihe mit
reis milch und cherry blossom so saß ich
finde es wirklich ganz ok aus ist aus
dieser reihe und wie ich schon gesagt
hat das ist mir so ein bisschen zu süß
dieser dürfte packen arbeit am 22
[Musik]
ritschel aufkam das ist so ein gras
glitzerndes radio
ich mache es mir hier so auf meinen
handrücken
doch wo
ihr doch dann glitzert man glück hat auf
jeden fall nicht in bar dann kann ich
das ja gleich
drauf schmieren ja ich finde zum
beispiel wenn man ausgeht dann finde ich
so ein body oil eigentlich ziemlich gut
weil dann sieht die haut nicht so
trocken aus man sieht ein bisschen
frösche aus vielleicht glitzert man
sogar noch ein bisschen und dann sitzt
du in der bar oder tanzt im klub und
denkst du bist in einem showroom days
music video täter tolles produkt ja was
ist anderes sehen was rauskommt bitte
bitte zeigt mir da was anderes türchen
nummer 23 vor letztes türchen einen tag
vor weihnachten und wir bekommen
ja ich denke mal ihr wisst was ist da
steckt man die holz dinge da so rein
dann saugt sich das holz damit voll und
dann hat man einen schönen raumduft und
jetzt ist der tag gekommen leute
moment you been waiting for
wenn es jetzt nichts ganz
außergewöhnliches gibt nun jetzt kommt
der 24 es ist heiligabend und wir haben
hat es ist eine parfüm werdet ihr mir
böse wenn ich das aufmachen würde also
ich kann es probieren und ich kann es ja
dann eigentlich noch verlosen wenn ich
da einmal raus sprühe das ist ja nicht
unhygienisch
beachtet es war dieser rosendorf
scheiße trickbetrügerin die ich bin
politisch hier wieder zu eine 50
milliliter flasche von diesem parfum
kostet 42 euro 50 das sind 15 milliliter
also preislich gesehen ist man hier
wahrscheinlich tip top aufgestellt sind
wir aber nicht vergessen dass er mittels
preise sind ich weiß nicht wie sie es
hinbekommen aber ich finde die produkte
haben auch so einen hochwertigen duft
sie sehen nicht nur hochwertig aus die
riechen halt auch einfach anders
lohnt sich voll aber man muss auch fan
von jedem duft sein ich finde nämlich
gerade bei bad tölz habe ich so zwei
favorite sie dunkelgrün finde ich super
und halt ritschel auf mehr so und bei
den anderen also man kann ja nicht alle
dürfte total feiern außer man feiert
alle dürfte dann ist dieser
adventskalender wirklich perfekt finde
ansonsten ist es zuviel ritschel da
würde ich lieber so ein full size models
produkt in einem selbstgemachten
adventskalender packen so als highlight
ich glaube nämlich wenn man so viele
produkte hat wird viel rum stehen ich
sag mal so dieser kalender ist wirklich
wundervoll
aufgebaut aber ja doch ich würde mich
auch gerade wenn man so ritschel scan
ist dann ist das bestimmt perfekt also
nur will euer partner oder ihre
partnerin da ab und zu mal was kauf
würde ich jetzt nicht da so ein
adventskalender hinterher schmeißen weil
es wirklich viele düfte gibt die dann
vielleicht auch nicht so cool sind am
ende des tages ist das euer leben und
ich kann euch da nicht reinreden ich
hoffe ihr hattet spaß beim zuschauen wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder mit
einem neuen adventskalender wunder
wunder wer hätte es gedacht ganz ehrlich
bei